the dallas cowboys have yet to make a
big financial investment in running back
ezekiel late we feel like that is coming
another thing that we may need to pay
attention to that could be coming some
sort of league action we've talked about
this a few times arising from the video
of ezekiel elliott confronting a 19 year
old security guard at a music festival
in las vegas pushed up against him the
guy fell down the guy claims he was
shoved the video was inconclusive as to
whether or not there was a shove but
either way it was an aggressive posture
by ezekiel that caused the guy to back
up and eventually fall the dallas
morning news reported on wednesday that
the nfl immediately sought information
from the las vegas metropolitan police
department
as soon as the video surfaced so look
you know people say oh it's no big deal
the cowboys are we're not worried oh
it's nothing oh he didn't do anything
because elliot's already been suspended
for violating the personal conduct
policy he's inherently on thin ice
remember we made a lot about the letter
that was sent to elliot back in 2017
further
behavior of this nature could result in
banishment from the league so
they are watching they are reviewing
they are studying and if they come to
the conclusion that there was even a
slight violation of the personal conduct
policy chris his history is going to set
him up for more punishment and people
are going to be surprised if it happens
but i'm here to say do not rule it out
because the league is clearly on the
case and we'll see what they decide if
they decide there was a violation
we we may not be very happy with the end
result well ezekiel is uh you know like
you're saying he's on their radar so
yeah i mean
again i said this last week or two weeks
ago when they brought it up i don't
think this is a suspendable offense i
mean yes it's not the greatest look i
could see them maybe finding him if they
want to take away a game check maybe
something like that okay with the way
the nfl operates and things i i could
see them doing that but i really would
be shocked if it ended up in losing
losing him for a game or two just
because uh you know he aggressively
stepped into a 19 year old and again i'm
not condoning what ezekiel elliott did
and all that too but you know i guess
mike and maybe i'm wrong here but i'm
just throwing this off off of you
i mean have we heard anything from the
league about are they
looking up richie incognito and the
things he did in the off season and the
issues he's had i just feel he's he'll
be he no no no he cognito i think
incognito will be suspended he's got two
guilty pleas from two separate incidents
that happened last august so he he will
i think before the start of the regular
season he will be suspended for one or
more games so yes that that's uh that
one that one isn't as close of a
question i think the issue with elliot
is we see the video and we think well
like you say well that's really not a
suspendable offense but when you factor
in his history it becomes a suspendable
offense the problem is there are still
plenty of people who look at what was
done in 2017 and think that wasn't a
suspendable yes right right but it
doesn't matter it's on his record right
it's like the black mark on your record
i'm sure you have a few of those from an
academic standpoint from your time in in
school but no doubt i digress but uh but
that's so it's already there it's not
going away so the fact that it's there
makes this incident more problematic
from the league's perspective that's why
i added it to today's list of topics for
pftot because people need to be ready
for what could happen we know what to
expect from richie incognito we know
that tyree kill at some point is likely
going to find himself suspended with
ezekiel elliott if it happens there's
going to be some cowboys fans who are
pissed they're going to be fantasy
football owners who are pissed there's
going to be others who are just flat out
confused because they see that video and
they react the way you did i don't see
anything there you would suspend a guy
for right
and and you know i hope that the nfl can
take into account that i think their
last suspension i'll be one of those
guys that would say that i think was a
little too harsh for ezekiel elliot i
think there was some you know holes in
what the nfl did as far as obtaining
some information without getting into
all the details and everything like that
i'm not so i'm not gonna sit here and
say that i definitely thought that
warranted a six-game suspension that
year so maybe they can take that into
account i don't know to me it just
sometimes mike i look at it i see like
the nfl pursues
some people's things more aggressively
than others and i don't understand that
at times maybe i'm maybe i'm not wrong i
didn't know we were about to talk about
this so i'm kind of going off the top of
my head here but yeah i just
i know it seems like some players they
aggressively go we want to get the
information and then other ones it's
just like oh we're going to kind of wait
back and see before we actually try to
get the information on that one
i think for some players and i'm not
talking specifically about elliott here
for some players they develop a belief
as to who he is and what he is and what
they conclude may be different from what
the public image is so in their mind
it's justified to be aggressive because
for everything they get him for there's
five other things he's getting away with
and again i'm not saying that that's
elliot but it could be they have flagged
him that way that this is a guy who you
know maybe he parties too much maybe
he's involved in too many things that
are close to the line maybe he doesn't
really comport himself the way we would
like and this is our way to try to
engineer his behavior when he does cross
the line we're going to get him so maybe
he will stay away from the line all
together instead of dancing on it again
i don't know that that's how they feel
about elliott if they do i don't believe
it's justified my point is that's a good
theory
i think there's a lot of justification
for how aggressively and look
prosecutors do the same thing they're
going to be more inclined to go after
somebody for a relatively meaningless
offense if they believe this is a bad
person who gets away with a lot of stuff
again i'm not saying that that's elliot
but that would explain the motivation
that for whatever reason they believe
that eliot did the things that he was
suspended for even if he didn't get a
fair chance to prove that he didn't and
maybe they're still frustrated with
elliot for fighting it as hard as he did
because it made them look like a
keystone cop organization presided over
by a kangaroo court so they may have
some lingering animosity about that as
well yeah that you're you're that that
was a lot of good stuff there that's why
you're a lawyer that's why you're mike
floria i i'm not anymore
you know the anniversary is coming up
july 1 will be 10 years since uh we
officially joined nbc 10 years that's
awesome man that's that's cool to hear i
mean yeah you've done a good job man i
think you made the right career choice i
bet you weren't a very good lawyer
you're pretty good at pro football talk
[ __ ] oops
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports